wird uns auf dem mars das blut
ausgesaugt ein forschungsteam aus
manchester hat jetzt eine verstörende
studie veröffentlicht demnach können wir
auf dem roten planeten unterkünfte mit
menschlichem blut bauen und nicht nur
das kriegs uns im future gibt es dreimal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und activity glocke
nur so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen wenn wir die
existenz der menschheit auch in der
zukunft sichern wollen müssen wir zu
neuen welten aufbrechen genau davon was
stephen hawking überzeugt denn das leben
auf der erde ist in ständiger bedrohung
egal ob durch den klimawandel pandemien
super vulkane oder asteroiden nur noch
einige hundert jahre zeit haben wir laut
stephen hawking um in die weiten des
weltalls aufzubrechen auch zukunfts
forscherinnen und forscher sind
überzeugt davon dass eine spezies die
dauerhaft überleben will auf fremden
planeten siedeln muss zunächst wird es
höchstwahrscheinlich der mode sein den
wir erobern eine mondstation und der
lunar orbiter plattform geht während
allerdings nur ein zwischenschritt in
richtung mars dort oben auf dem roten
planeten soll dann langfristig gesehen
eine maß kolonie errichtet werden
weltraum organisationen auf der ganzen
welt haben genau dieses eine ziel doch
die herausforderungen sind groß und eine
davon ist die frage welche materialien
die astronauten astronauten für den bau
der kolonie verwenden könnten das
problem dem mars untergrund fehlt es
genau wie der mond erde an
druckfestigkeit und widerstandskraft
einen wirklich ich sage mal
interessanten vorschlag für die lösung
dieses problems hat jetzt ein britisches
forschungsteam in einer aktuellen studie
veröffentlicht die nötigen materialien
könnten direkt aus dem menschlichen
körper kommen wird uns also auf dem mars
bald das blut ausgesaugt alle spannenden
infos zu diesem thema gibt es jetzt bei
klicks zum science in future spacex und
tesla chef elon musk ist ganz vorne mit
dabei er will so schnell wie möglich zum
mars und dem wegbereiter dafür und der
kolonisation des gesamten weltraum
starship das raumschiff soll zunächst in
eine erdumlaufbahn und dort auf
treibstofftanks treffen die vorab in den
erdorbit geschossen worden sind diese
sind gefüllt mit methan und sauerstoff
und treiben die rakete auf dem flug zum
mars an die ersten missionen sollen nach
wasser und rohstoffen suchen und zu dem
auch die möglichen risiken und gefahren
für menschen checken die ersten menschen
die dann zum mars fliegen sollen
produzieren dort den treibstoff für den
rückflug zur erde 4 sa ships sollen
zunächst zum mars fliegen zwei benannt
und zwei umbenannt mit diesen flügen
könnte dann die erste kolonie aufgebaut
werden ihnen musk dazu wir werden zum
mond fliegen wir werden eine basis auf
dem mond haben wir werden zum mars
fliegen eine mission zum mond ist dabei
aber deutlich realistischer als eine
landung auf dem mars eine der größten
herausforderung die landung auf dem mars
denn das landen hier ist äußerst
kompliziert dass hatten nasa missionen
in der vergangenheit gezeigt und das
obwohl diese flugkörper deutlich kleiner
waren asiatische press steht das
raumschiff wurde mit einer
geschwindigkeit von rund 27.000
kilometern pro stunde in die atmosphäre
das maß eintreten wegen der extremen
temperaturen dort hat elena six
raumfahrtunternehmen spacex das material
das raumschiff auch noch mal von
kohlenstofffaser zu stark ändern doch
nicht nur die landung auf dem roten
planeten stellt die fachleute weltweit
für herausforderung auch die frage wie
der bau der mars kolonie selbst
vonstatten gehen könnte die ist noch
unbeantwortet
die mas erde selbst eignet sich nicht
und so wurde in der vergangenheit vieles
ausprobiert dazu der britische
wissenschaftler robert wissenschaftler
haben versucht praktikable technologien
zur herstellung von beton ähnlichen
materialien auf der mars oberfläche zu
entwickeln aber wir haben nie daran
gedacht dass die antwort vielleicht in
uns selbst liegt für den bau eines mond
postens gilt dieselbe herausforderung
auch hier werden nicht nur türen fenster
eine startplattform ein mondfahrzeug ein
gewächshaus ein treibstofftank sondern
auch ein druckbehälter für sauerstoff
benötigt auch hier haben fachleute
weltweit verschiedene lösungsansätze die
esa tüftelt an einem konzept bei dem mit
hilfe eines 3d druckers aus dem
mondstaub eine station entstehen könnte
einen 1,5 tonnen schweren prototypen
gibt es bereits einfach eine mail
schicken und die teile die auf dem mond
gebraucht werden werden vor ort gedruckt
doch hier gab es bislang eine weitere
große herausforderung woher soll das
bindemittel auf dem mond genommen werden
das erst dafür sorgt dass das material
beim druck gut formbar ist und nach dem
erstarren stabil wird ohne aber dabei
risse zu bilden im klartext um aus dem
mond regolith mit hilfe des 3d drucks
wand teile herzustellen braucht es
wasser und zudem ein weich machen das
bindemittel auf der erde kein problem
hier wird dafür nach tallinn oder pulli
cabuk salat genutzt und auf dem mond
fachleute aus norwegen haben vor einiger
zeit für genau diese frage eine passende
antwort gefunden sie schlagen urin der
zukünftigen mond bewohnerinnen und
bewohner vor den urin besteht
hauptsächlich aus stoff und wasser und
eignet sich somit hervorragend als
bindemittel lieferant und weichmacher
die forschenden konnten in ihren
experimenten zeigen dass sich haben
stoff ähnlich gut wie gängige
bindemittel eignet ein regolith analog
als mondstaub ersatz wurde dafür mit
wasser und entweder harnstoff nach
tallinn poly cabuk salat oder keine
bindemittel angerührt das ergebnis war
eindeutig die mischung mit harnstoff
erwies sich als weich genug umgeformt zu
werden dennoch war sie auch stabil genug
um danach in form zu bleiben dieses
ergebnis ist vergleichbar mit den
eigenschaften der herkömmlichen
bindemittel doch nicht nur das das
forschungsteam schreibt in seiner neuen
studie die harnstoff mischung zeigt eine
relativ hohe anfängliche kompression
stabilität heißt also dass die bauteile
aus der harnstoff regolith mischung
ähnlich stabil sind wie das mit gängigen
bindemitteln hepstedt material auch nach
dem erhitzen auf 80 grad und mehreren
zyklen folge frieren und auen wiesen
sich die bauteile noch als stabil als
bindemittel wirkt harnstoff so gut weil
es in der lage ist
wasserstoffbrückenbindungen aufzubrechen
so kann es die viskosität von
wasserhaltigen mischung verringert ein
wirklich überraschendes ergebnis also
aus norwegen das trotz seiner
einfachheit überzeugt das fazit der
fachleute ist positiv damit zeigt
harnstoff eigenschaften die ihn zu einem
vielversprechenden zusatzstoff für
lunare biopolymere machen ob der hand
stoff zuvor aus dem urin extrahiert
werden muss oder ob man nicht auch den
kompletten urin nutzen könnte müssen wir
noch auch die fachleute aus manchester
sind in ihrer aktuellen studie auf die
idee gekommen sich menschliche
körperflüssigkeiten für den aufbau einer
kolonie im weltraum zu nutze zu machen
denn die astronautin astronauten sind ja
eh vor ort um die siedlung zu errichten
egal ob auf dem mond oder dem mars die
britischen fachleute nahmen ein
bestimmtes protein aus dem menschlichen
blutplasma genauer ins visier konkret
handelt es sich dabei um serum albumin
ein eiweiß das im menschlichen körper
wichtige aufgaben übernimmt
beispielsweise spielt es eine
entscheidende rolle bei der flüssigkeit
verteilung innerhalb und außerhalb der
zellen und außerdem dient es als
transport stoff doch nicht nur in
unserem körper könnte es entscheidend
sein die britischen wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler haben herausgefunden
dass dieses protein aus dem blutplasma
auch für den bau einer mars kolonie
genutzt werden könnte denn die
experimente der fachleute offenbarten
dass es sich gut als bindemittel für
außerirdischen staub handelt das produkt
das bei diesen experimenten entstanden
war bezeichnen die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler als astrid also
astro tom quasi abgekürzt und dieses
material hat nach angaben des
forschungsteams eine druckfestigkeit von
25 megapascal zum vergleich die
festigkeit von herkömmlichem beton liegt
bei 20 bis 32 megapascal doch die
druckfestigkeit haben die fachleute
sogar noch weiter erhöht und zwar durch
die zugabe von harnstoff klein effekt am
rande dieser ist nicht nur menschlichen
urin zu finden sondern auch in unserem
schweiß und unseren tränen so konnte die
druckfestigkeit um mehr als 8 300
prozent erhöht werden am ende wies das
leistungsstärkste astrid eine festigkeit
von rund 40 megapascal auf deutlich mehr
also als gewöhnlicher beton wird jetzt
also blut auf dem mars zum gold für die
besiedlung und wie kommen wir dann an
die mengen für den bau von gebäuden
fragen über fragen und beim nachdenken
schau dass einem ein wenig apropos
ziemlich verblüffend das ist die größte
gefahr im weltraum anklicken anschauen
und abonnieren das geht mit dem abo
button unter jedem video also bis dann
bleibt dran und schaut euch dieses video
an verblüffend und spannend